Zod's Arbenz that's pretty good there's
a hint of Elmo in there yeah this means
I can I can diverge when I when I need
to no it means you're gonna like ruin
Star Wars and also teach us the alphabet
what's up guys welcome to binge watch
I'm Lucy joined as ever by day hello and
hello the book bookmarks if introducing
themselves there guys we're here to talk
about mr. robot season two the first
three episodes are out we've watched
them now we are big fans of season 1
right yeah season 1 big fans are very
very big fan of season 1 we'd love that
show when it was on when it's airing the
first time we talked about it all the
time it's a real water cooler type thing
for us
now this isn't too started we aren't as
impressed I think it's fair to say which
is quite annoying
what are annoying but it's kind of
disappointing because we were such big
fans of season 1 so we're kind of coming
at this from a fan perspective and these
are it's basically where we think season
2 is making a few missteps in its first
few episodes so beware for spoilers we
would probably spoil all season 1 and
the first three episodes of season to
see happen more we've each picked one
thing that we think is a major sticking
point in the series so far so Dave
you're gonna kick things off you're not
happy with the show's perception of
reality yeah in the first season the
breaks in reality it was like it was
like a big twist we didn't know that
Elliott was actually like imagining a
whole bunch of stuff until right at the
end and it was kind of like it's a big
shock but with three episodes of the
season two and has already been so much
of that that it's just completely lost
its intensity all the drama intrigue
imagination of Elliott's reality is just
is just gone it's it feels like it's
been overused it's it's almost like it's
a movie the ends and then it was all a
dream
mmm it's just like ah really that was
like a cool two hours and I was taken
away from me in Episode three Elliott
takes a whole bunch of adderall to take
to get mr. Roboto his head to allow him
to focus and as soon as he does that
he's abducted by what he says what he
assumes of the FBI they taken to a
warehouse they force-feed him cement
which is like a really gross intense
scene if that was like in a gangster
movie that'd be like really made the
scene like I wanted to be sat there I
wanted to be thinking how is that he
gonna go this what's going on who are
these guys and then just as it was
getting really intense
it was like it's not really happening
it's not real sorry about that he's just
actually just throwing up on the floor
yeah I was like that could have been so
cool that could have been something but
instead it was you know over did you
make dream sequence basically yeah it's
also kind of it would have been cool
because it the minute Elliot also has no
real repercussions so I thought that
would have really moved the story along
if like the FBI had been getting
involved there but I'm interested to
know what you guys think do you think
that like the breaks in reality it kind
of getting overused at this point I
think they are getting overused and in
that one specifically we've reached a
point where we can tell it's a break in
reality which gives it no sort of like
any sort of impact yeah so like the
moment starts something really extreme
starts happening I think we all go it's
not real yeah and then it's just a
matter of whether they can make it
interesting in that case it was kind of
interesting they cut to the vomit which
is a cool way of moving you know vomit
representing the actual cement which was
nice but it had no tension to it because
we knew straight away ice mr. robot
screwing with him again yeah I think
they're gonna there's gonna be another
big like shocking reveal look not like
the mr. robot twist I think but there's
a big theory online that Elliot's not
actually staying at his mum's house he's
actually in prison and if you think
about the way he's got such a fixed
routine and the way that he gets
visitors the way it gets his phone call
the way he looks at basketball goes to
rehab all very similar ways to the the
kind of program that you have if you're
in prison or in a mental institution so
I'm kind of thinking that that's maybe
where that's going and that they're
really trying to hammer home that
nothing is real everything's an illusion
there is no control but at the point I'm
at the point now where I'm just getting
fed up of it yeah it's definitely a fine
line to walk what's real and what's not
and four episodes in I think already I
feel I think they're doing it wrong
Tamino you're not happy with the show's
pacing in season 2 yeah the pacing and
the energy the first three episodes of
season 1 were super intense
I was watching our recap which you can
find on youtube.com forward slash
GameSpot and they were very focused on
introducing relevant and
[ __ ] and plot points and characters
there was almost like this cause and
effect type dynamic between that like
you knew when something new was
introduced you're like how does this fit
into episode you know the grander story
sorry
so just a couple of things quickly run
through for the first three episodes of
season one he joined a hacker group
learned of the plan to bring down Ecore
met Tyrell American Psycho dude
Tyrell beat up a hobo we realized that
he's addicted to morphine
there's Cisco and allsafe and Gideon
investigated a lot of things that kind
of moved the plot forward so far in
season 2 all we've had is basically kind
of wallowing around in Elliott's psyche
F Society trying to get their act
together it's not really pushing the
plot forward which is not what you want
after the last thing we saw them do was
pretty much bring the wall to a
standstill yeah so my problem with it is
that like the lack of intensity that
energy the momentum is completely gone
and like have you guys encountered
anything in season 2 that kind of
matches up to anything we've had in the
first three episodes of season 1 I don't
think anything matches it so far there's
a few interesting characters like Rey
for example and like we simply swimming
that in episode 3 he's on dialysis and
he copes with his wife's death by by
just imagining talking to her and we see
we see a man meet another like network
engineer who's been beaten up there's
this there's a bit going on with him and
he's really the only person yeah I feel
like attached to there's a bunch for the
character that we introduced I'm just
like why are they here you've not told
me why I should care about its character
yet yeah I agree I don't know I think
there's a couple of moments you know
when Gideon gets shot in the bar and
also I thought when Angela now that
she's at a co-op and when she's on the
phone even though like the Bloomberg
interview seems like a really
inconsequential thing the tension about
her fitting into that job and the way
that she was you know slamming down the
phone and taking calls and you were
seeing what would happen there that I
felt like had the same kind of energy
but the plot point doesn't seem as big
so it doesn't seem as important yeah I
think Angela is maybe I want
of interest in the story because it was
not quite clear whether she's fully been
indoctrinated into the corporate society
or if she's playing a look like a bit of
a con so that could but at the same time
the characters kind of boring I find ray
I find quite interesting he could be
what brings Elliot back to his you know
digital state now that he's living in
analog but so season 1 episodes 1 to 3
were written by the show creator Sam SML
and he's writing the entirety of season
2 and directing and direct from the look
of it which is slightly worrying I feel
like we might be in a lost situation
where it was designing said listen lost
was fine first season but then you know
they realized this is big we need to
make this yeah and I feel like it's that
as well and also he had an interview Sam
it's no with II W and it said this he
said the same thing he's thinking about
season two and three and he wants less
of a break between those so it's that's
kind of worrying me about stretching it
too thin also what's worrying me is that
the script especially in the second
season is getting very self-indulgent
there's some real Kleiner's of lines as
well well like when Tyrells on the phone
Tim he's like to know what's going on
oh how I wish how I wish and it seems
like there's no one there really saying
to be the back of it maze alright
talking about his con yeah I never con
without confidence and this this episode
the moment where Elliot just starts
raggin on all religions as like calm
down yourself on the edge bring it back
a bit you know so I feel like it's great
to have a vision and showed like Sam as
man he's he's the vision behind it it's
his baby but I'm wondering if he's gets
too much into Auto territory and no
one's gonna tell him that maybe this
isn't the best thing for the show yeah
my gripe is quite similar to yours timer
I think that the show is pretty much
losing focus do you think about season 1
right the plot of season 1 hacker group
takes down multi-billion dollar evil
corporation right you can set you can
explain it in a sentence what made the
show really interesting is it had all
these threads so you had you know Elliot
and Angela both losing parents because
of evil Corp and that's why they were so
invested in it you had like the drug
dealers you had all safe you had Darlene
that revelation and then you had the mr.
robot stuff which was pretty much like
an afterthought right it wasn't
completely driving the main plot forward
so guys I'll put it to you explain what
season 2 is in a sentence I don't think
I could do it I really couldn't do it in
a sense so far it's ex hacker man is sad
yeah I think it's Wright's long Diaries
impossible to do it whilst also bearing
in mind season 1 because like if you
want to explain to like someone who's
seen season 1 why they should come back
to season 2 it's impossible because like
based on those three episodes it's
almost like a different show it's not
even the same show it feels like that I
mean the characters are there but it's
no longer the thrust of you know what
the first season was about almost none
of it is represented in season 2 I mean
the sum up for season 1 is like you
meant you have to mention hacking yes
there's not been any hacking in season 2
yet I mean they hacked that smart house
yeah that that was quite scary yeah and
a bank but it wasn't anything
significant I feel like it was just it's
just them being prankster
essentially so what I think is like
season two seems to just be piggybacking
off all these different threads but
nothing's really coming together yet did
you take like f society right they've
committed and they've actually said this
in the show it's the biggest crime in
the last century and they've essentially
brought the American economy to a
complete standstill and yet you kind of
see it in news reports but no one
directly in the show seems to be
suffering from it like Romero's mum the
guy who died in the last episode his mum
was like oh yeah I'm gonna sell the
place because I need the money
who is gonna be buying property if the
entire economy is in crisis it just
doesn't there's no urgency in it doesn't
seem like they've got to the end of
basically this end of the world stay
yeah it comes in and out at all like
paying for the meal upfront Angela and
her bosses that's kind of like a small
nod to it but I don't think it's
anything significant I guess that's part
of the point like a Corp has feel it
seems like they've not suffered much
from the attack but at the same time the
wall the random should reflect it a
little more eco should be you know this
this kind of like stronghold for like
you know consumerism look we can we can
dis pounces off of us yeah but we want
to be able to see how it effects the
people and we're not see enough of that
we get a little bit hair in there but I
feel like they should be setting up y.f
society needs to double down on their
efforts
why equip are still evil and this is why
we need to still go after them it just
doesn't seem like it's doing that it's
just like I remember those bad guys from
you know the the last season yeah we
kicked them a bit we're gonna carry on
kicking them but none of the kind of
things like losing parents are there any
more to give you that kind of drive to
be like yeah I want to see if society
take them down it's just like we just
want to bring down this bank and also
your relationship I mean in season one
was with Elliott because he talked to
you so much yeah you had that
relationship and he was like this
driving force pulling you through the
story but now that he's become this
unreliable narrator I don't want to
trust anything he says I don't want to
listen to my don't I'm not invested in
his story as much because I don't
believe in it so that's kind of you know
it's not pulling me through so I'm not
very interested yeah Elliott as a
character he was he's one of those
people who
a lot of shows where they wallow in
their own sadness but what and I usually
hate that but what made him interesting
was at the same time as having that he
had this other side to him which was
fiercely like objective-based
and he had these these ambitions and he
focused on that and it was part of those
two kind of flavors of the character
that bounced off each other and kind of
made it interesting now it's just he's
just that one wallowing sad dude and
he's not really getting anything done
which makes him a like an annoying
character now because I I feel like they
are slowly like snail's pace completely
introducing these points I think ray is
there to drag Elliot back in right
you've got the FBI agent and you know
these and these murders happening so I
feel like consequences are coming but
just the way and how slowly they've been
introduced it doesn't feel like eff
Society have done anything yeah that
like like you say before Eko orgasm
hasn't suffered the scenes in which
they're showing the people are suffering
kind of feel forced and they said you
expect such book more grandiose plot
points considering they did the biggest
crime well I mean they're they're
quarter of the way through the season
now yeah which is no way to thank you
but I don't know I'm hoping you know
stuff kicks off yeah we're being a
little bit down on the show but there
are some redeeming quality so Dave what
were you enjoying of all the characters
that been introduced I think ray is is I
think the best I was ready to dislike
ray just because not dislike him I just
felt his dramatic role was a bit weird
because I'm so used to seeing that axon
in comedic roles yeah but especially
since the last episode and you've seen
his is some of his mental stuff and some
of the stuff that he's up against and
that the manipulation and intrigue of
him I think he could actually one of the
cooler characters and especially if it
drags early out of his slump town what
about you I really like Leon which is
Elliott's new friend partly because he's
a Seinfeld quote and he's like he's
trying to figure out the Seinfeld which
is brilliant and but also because he's
one of my favorite rappers his name is
Joey badass he's got a great album you
should check it out
I love the
his in the credits but I like him as a
character he's kind of like if it is
existing in the prison world which is a
theory like he's the cool guy that hooks
you up and you know he seems to be like
the kind of character one of the
characters that may kind of Elliott may
take a long for the ride a lot of the
other characters feel a bit
inconsequential to me or maybe it's just
I want him to be taken along for the
ride he's were so kind of helping
Elliott get control of mr. robot so I
like him he's it's mainly the Seinfeld
stuff where he's like dude Kramer's
worst I quite like Angela I like she's
always kind of been on a bit on the back
foot never really doing anything but I
like that she's turned into this
corporate [ __ ] but you don't know if
you can if you she's really invested in
it and it's this weird relationship
she's got going on with Phillip price
and you don't know who's got what
motivations it's very cool and you know
the when they have a dinner scene just I
don't know why I was expecting was it
meant to be a day and then you find out
it was this and then Phillip like pause
the raga and it's like you can send
these guys away yeah and I thought that
was I thought that was a quite a cool
plot point because I was worried that
they weren't gonna do anything with the
parent death thing but she fits into
Elliot's thing about faces as well and
wearing masks and that kind of stuff
because we see her regularly watching
these weird videos about reinforcing
sell DVDs yeah and it's hard to tell
whether that's what she's trying to do
to fit into her new role and it's
fighting against her you know her normal
nature or whether it's kind of like how
she's embodying this double-crosser by
telling herself to be this person so
yeah she's interesting I feel like yeah
but I mean we were a quarter the way
through the season plenty more still to
come so for more mr. robot make sure you
stay tuned to binge watch here on
youtube.com slash GameSpot if you like
the video don't forget to like subscribe
to the channel for more you can find me
on Twitter I'm at Lisa James games I'm
at a regular date and I'm at two more H
and we'll see you soon